uh also really great what we're going to
begin this hour with a familiar problem
for all you at home you open the fridge
and it's full of leftovers none of it
looks very good and what do you do you
toss it out here's a different idea kind
of old-fashioned you could cook with
them that is the notion behind the
Everlasting meal cookbook leftovers A to
Z happens to be published by an imprint
of Simon Schuster which like CBS is part
of Paramount Global also happens to be
by author Tamar Adler who made me into
the family Chef she calls it leftovers a
leftovers encyclopedia and it's
organized by Leftover that means there
are entries for all the things you might
guess like stale bread and take out rice
and hamburger patties but also a lot of
stuff you wouldn't guess like parmesan
rinds and tomatoes a little bit of mold
and also like stale bags of Doritos you
know I know you have them what it all
has in common and I know because I have
lived the leftover Lifestyle the
Everlasting meal lifestyle for years now
I'm looking at people looking at me
right now tomorrow either she can make
it delicious
we still put her to the test
we arrive hello
and things are not what you'd expect I
brought you uh old bread from lunch at a
friend's place I'm so excited for this
you probably recognize our hosts that
CBS business analyst Jill Schlesinger
one of the few people I know game enough
to allow camera Crews into her living
space for a close-up examination of her
leftovers tomorrow if you feel
comfortable good luck I've also invited
Tamar Adler author of a cookbook called
the Everlasting meal a collection of
more than 1500 recipes designed for
using up your leftovers all right let's
see what we got
oh this is amazing we start with an
inventory of the fridge this looks very
promising this is a little leftover
Chinese food and what comes out is not
what most folks would call appetizing
that is old butternut squash noodles
some rubbery chicken stale tortillas I
could use that as a frisbee lots of
little mystery tubs I love old stuff you
have all of my favorite ingredients here
down in the freezer don't judge me you
two never Tamar finds a forgotten gem
Frozen Bagels which are not great but
you feel free to use them you do you
girl
and over in the cupboards once again
Treasures yeah look at that look at that
she finds a whole bunch of neglected
ingredients then over here but is
especially excited I see our guy about a
bag of mixed nuts and just like that do
you need a little knife to cut that no
no you've got fingers I have fingers
we've got a countertop full of sad
leftovers that Tamar assures us can be
reborn but first I have to tell you
Tamar Adler is who turned me into the
family Chef after I read her 2011 book
about the beauty of cooking whatever you
have when you start getting on one of
these kicks of like once you've made
this and then you're halfway to that and
then you're halfway to this there's like
a kind of mad genius effect which I
appreciate it's like one of those great
things because every single person has
this exact situation right like this is
not this is like the state of every
single person's fridge and household
it's like you too could be imaginious
she developed that philosophy as head
chef of a restaurant in Georgia short on
money and ingredients we can't afford to
buy more stuff we have these things that
we have here
um and I just burned the rice like that
was my restaurant that was my restaurant
I was like welcome
to the restaurant where we cook whatever
we have and we burn the rice and we
totally did so what's the lesson there
for people who are trying to cook for
friends coming over and they're not
professional chefs and they're nowhere
near even going in the direction of
professional it's
nobody cares
people come over for as the experience
of being served and that people love
being hosted oh we'll use this too back
with our host Jill are these are these a
little bit scalded though they are we
burn the nuts and it's not always clear
that things are going to work how's it
taste
um
okay but true to form Tamar Powers us
onward that's great
after all whole lot of chopping I would
just go through this one more time to
make it a little bit smaller some
shredding and some slicing she's such a
pro look at that look at look at that
look at the nice skills a little mashing
and mixing see that looks so delicious
this looks truly so great this looks
amazing plus a stovetop trick with the
tortillas look what's going on over here
Holy Spirit we're back to life and this
move with the baguette so what we're
gonna do is just this that involved a
little time in the oven all right so
this is what I get so excited we had our
meal
dish number one is shredded chicken with
corn and lime over fried tortillas dish
number two a rice salad with a simple
vinaigrette and roasted nuts and Dish
three smashed veggies on a little garlic
rubbed bread and bagel pieces you could
do a multiple choice of like what was
this before and people would struggle
yeah
straw you'd never know the back story
and when we finally taste it I love the
rice salad thank you very much it's
clear
this time there won't be any leftovers
it's good they're totally like a great
chicken tostada in the end tomorrow says
this is the point like it it's just
cooking it's fundamental cooking like
there's not a special although it's true
that I particularly like using what's
there and kind of like solving these
problems I think all cooking is actually
problem solving and so it is Magic and
it feels like magic but I think it's
really
attainable Magic
and I am proof that it can be attained
oh my gosh and it is just cooking it's
old-fashioned using what you got cooking
and that's what I did with these Aaron
Chini which is fried rice balls they are
so good so it's leftover risotto which I
made for dinner yesterday I used a
leftover onion for that by the way so
this is multiple generations of
leftovers I plucked it out of some
tomato sauce
I need a bro bump I got I got leftover
vermouth from the holidays in there and
also uh stale bread which you grind up
which is the coating on this so can I
tell you I attempted rice balls
okay
they were so goodness awful they were
just ridiculous what are you doing here
that's different from what I attempted
to do are you just fried it in some oil
how you roll it up but one thing that
she said that was really important I
think was that when you have leftovers
sometimes having something really good
that can really Jazz it up like if you
have a very good olive oil in your
cabinet it can make a huge difference
and as Tony showed me it's the cutting
and my technique I agree Nate not great
but it was really interesting to be like
hey I had some old old roast chicken and
how we chopped that up and like you
change the texture of it you add some
olive oil throw some herbs in there
pretty good I know it's amazing I want
the book that's the way to go repurpose
food you Reaper this is what it used to
be like it's just cooking right it's
very simple it saves money yeah great
money reset over there it saves waste
and it's delicious and all I did is look
up risotto because I had that was if you
look it up by leftovers I looked up
risotto and then it gave me the recipe
for this you can keep that coffee I'm
keeping this car
the Everlasting deal cookbook and it
goes on sale tomorrow